- Sup 2018?
- Hey, we're gonna be
tryin' out some foods today.
- Maybe you've heard of the dollar menu.
- Oh yeah, that's your
favorite discount duo.
- Discount duo!
Some would call us a broke Worth It.
(laughing)
- Yeah, we're gonna be tryin'
out the dollar menu today
at a bunch of different restaurants.
- Bunch of different restaurants.
(laughing)
- Let's go to Taco Bell first.
- I've had Taco Bell recently.
I'm more excited for Wendy's,
I don't know if that's
important information.
- I love Wendy's.
Wendy's is my favorite, but
we're on our way to Taco Bell
(laughing)
- We're just gonna talk about Wendy's.
♪ Taco Taco Bell ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ I want to eat at Taco Bell ♪
- [Worker] Hi, how can I help you?
- I'm gonna get the cheesy
bean and rice burrito
(sped up talking)
and a spicy tostada.
Yes.
- Welcome to the after party.
- Oh, I smell it all.
We're doing it in the order
that we pull these out.
Oh, classic cinnamon twists.
- Twists.
A pleasant styrofoam.
I can't tell if this is a dessert.
It's so hot, it's so hot.
(screams)
- Oh my god, that's hot.
- Oh baby, I like her.
Oh, I'm excited for these!
They're gonna be good.
- [Jared] I'm enticed.
- I wouldn't hate a guac and
a little bit of sour cream.
- Do they have guac?
- I don't think so.
I'm gonna open the next thing.
I'm gonna take a bite from this end
then I'll pass it over.
- Okay.
We're not gonna Lady and The Tramp it.
- Mm!
How do I feel about Fritos?
- Fritos, the chip.
- Oh, I love Fritos.
It tastes like the
inside of a cabin smells.
- It does.
It's a very...
There's a smokiness.
More nachos.
- Oh,
here it is.
Oh, a spork!
- Did Taco Bell invent the spork?
That's where I first encountered them.
- In she goes.
I just like new ways
to eat the same thing.
Oh, the bag doesn't end.
Oh!
- Whoa, that is...
It is cheesy rice and beany.
- I want to eat this
while I'm falling asleep.
I have a feeling I'm
not gonna love this one.
It's just gonna be cheese.
Dry.
- It's cheese
and dry.
(humming)
Oh my god, there's still more.
- I've had enough.
- They gave us two.
- They gave us two!
- [Jared] And one's chicken, one's beef.
- My mouth just farted.
Did you hear that?
(laughing)
More?
- They're cinnamon rolls.
- I don't want it.
- Okay, I thought they were
gonna be like a cinnamon bun.
Oh, they're inside!
The goo's inside.
- Oh.
What a nice surprise.
- Is it?
That was pretty good.
A lot of redundancies.
- A lot of redundancies.
- I would give it a seven outta 10.
- All of it?
Total?
Their dollar menu?
- Total, yeah.
- This the value of their dollar?
♪ We're going to try a dollar menu today ♪
♪ Gonna eat it right down
in the old fashioned way ♪
♪ Through your mouth ♪
♪ In USA ♪
(laughing)
- [Kate] The old fashioned way
of eating through your mouth.
- I'm trying to get
everything on the dollar menu
that's a dollar.
What do you want to drink?
- I would like, believe
it or not, a Diet Coke.
- This is gonna be exciting.
(humming)
Let's just pop right in.
- They're all so hot.
It really is made fresh.
Here you go, buddy.
- Oh no!
- It is pretty good.
- It's a little too wet for me.
- That's what she said.
(laughing)
The classic cheeseburger.
Why are they so good?
- I like the tiny lil' onions.
It's like different layers,
but the same layer at the same time.
- This is the good stuff, baby.
- Two regular McChickens and a spicy.
(laughing)
They should just put two or three
chicken McNuggets in there.
The cheeseburger was so happy
and then
- We should have waited.
- We should've waited.
You know, seven outta 10.
- Seven outta 10 for Mickey D's?
I was gonna give them a six outta 10.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because of those
chicken sandwiches.
(burps)
Alright, we're at Wendy's now.
I'm gonna get three four for fours.
Alright, let's eat some food!
- Yeah!
Okay.
- Wendy's.
- So the four for four,
you get fries,
you get nuggets,
you get a drink,
and you get a sandwich
burger of your choosing.
We're in perfect sync.
- What's up with the fries?
- Where are the fries?
- Mhm.
Now, Wendy's used to have different fries.
Do you remember their older fries?
They would get wet in the bag,
- Yeah.
- which I liked.
Goin' on to the nuggets.
- Yeah, definitely better.
- These are good.
- Chicken meat.
- Onto the birds.
- [Jared] Crunchy munchy.
- Actually, that's a very
good chicken sandwich.
- [Jared] Junior bacon cheeseburger, baby.
- I love that they're square.
- It looks like a classic
drive-thru burger.
(laughing)
- That's good.
When am I gonna be vegetarian?
Not today.
10 outta 10.
I think for...
- The whole four for four thing.
- The four for four is so nice.
- But even if you don't
want all those things,
give it to a friend.
- This is totally not
brought to you by Wendy's,
but Wendy, if you wanna talk...
- Call Mr. Buzzfeed's office.
Well, let's go bring
this food back to Mark.
- Okay.
You're welcome, Mark.
You have a lot...
- You got a lot to catch up on.
Alright, got the food.
- Can I have one?
- Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
- I love chicken nuggets.
- We're gonna give the rest to Mark.
- [Kelsey] Take a nugg.
- Take a nugg, bro.
- That depends, how much did it cost?
- They're dollar nuggets.
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
(door squeaks)